i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
it's not it's not about winning an award
for me it's about
being able to shine light
will smith breaks down in tears
apologizing during his oscar's
acceptance speech after slapping chris
rock and hollywood is reacting to go
home and think about it
it was crazy though
shout out to will
how do you think they handle it from
here
how do they handle it
i plead the fifth on that one i don't
know i don't know how they handle that i
think that the two gentlemen need to
deal with it and i think that the
academy needs to deal with it the 53
year old actor took home the best actor
trophy for his role as richard williams
the father of venus and serena williams
in king richard if you don't have no
respect for yourself right now
you will never have none
at all but ahead of will's big win chris
made a crack about his wife jada pinkett
smith and her shaved head jada i love
you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it will
seems to laugh at first but then this
happens
[Laughter]
oh wow
wow
as for what happened next et learned
that denzel washington and tyler perry
pulled will aside for a private chat
during the commercial break e.t spoke
with denzel on the red carpet ahead of
the show he said emotions were running
high i mean you know it's a lot of
emotions this is a long time well i
think a long time coming for him and
it's a lot of emotion it's probably all
welling up in him right now so it better
be him it was him will won his very
first oscar and addressed the slap in
his speech i want to apologize to the
academy i want to apologize to my all my
fellow
nominees
um
this is a beautiful moment and i'm not
i'm not i'm not
crying
for winning an award it's not it's not
about winning an award for me it's about
the entire cast and crew of king richard
following the award show the academy put
out a statement on twitter writing they
do not condone violence of any form
and adding tonight we are delighted to
celebrate our 94th academy awards
winners who deserve this moment of
recognition from their peers and movie
lovers around the world now the scuffle
between chris and will was the hot topic
at the after parties and there's mixed
emotions about it like tiffany haddish
who has will's full support now i would
define tonight as a success
it was a great night tonight okay what
did you fall i seen a man
stand up for his wife
which we don't see that much anymore
that made me have hope and they put her
face up on the screen looked over at his
wife she was hurt meanwhile others like
john leguizamo found issues with will's
apology you know
i would like to more of a straight
apology
to chris you know
that would have been that would have
been great because i mean i thought
will's performance was amazing and i'm
sorry that he tarnished it with this
behavior you know
i mean we all nobody likes to be made
fun of but you got to have a sense of
humor about yourself can't take yourself
that seriously i mean we're just acting
you know let's just relax
as for will he was all smiles standing
by his family at vanity fair's big bash
and once the men in black star was
inside he showed no signs of anything
being wrong check this out that's will
jamming to his and dj jazzy jeff's hit
summertime
[Music]
you